la population mondiale a triplé depuis
les congés payés les nations unies
estiment que d'ici 5 ans en 2050 la
population mondiale sera pas augmenté
encore de plus de 2 milliards et à la
fin du siècle
nous serons sans doute à plus de 11
milliards d'habitants dans le monde
évidemment ce sont des personnes qui
avec l'augmentation à l'instar de ce qui
s'est produit dans les pays anciennement
développé déjà plus anciennement
d'europe
naturellement des etats-unis du japon un
petit terrain de vos cd à disons pour
faire simple et bien des populations en
acquérant de nouvelles ressources en
s'ouvrant aussi à de nouvelles
informations sur de nouvelles
destinations de nouveaux pays de
nouvelles cultures et s'approprie en
quelque sorte le désir de voyage et de
partager cette ce bénéfice dont les
catégories de plus fortunées du monde
on avait jusque là été les seuls à avoir
bénéficié et par conséquent peut-être
par mimétisme certainement aussi par
envie de du club par envie de consommer
aussi appartement où les ressources
individuelles progresse dans un certain
nombre de pays et même si elles
progressent de manière très inégalitaire
dans des pays comme l'inde bien d'autres
eh bien ce sont de nouveaux touristes
potentiels et ses nouveaux touristes
potentiels
lorsqu'on se rend par exemple en inde
vous voyez quand quelques années les
queues de visite du taj mahal se sont
allongés d'une manière inconcevable et
l'on se dit en voyant la proportion des
indiens qui visitent leur propre pays et
qui visitent en particulier taj mahal
qui leur première destination de visites
en général et bien qu'en sera-t-il dans
20 ou 30 ans c'est à dire que c'est tout
un continent qui s'inscrit dans les
nouvelles formes de la société de
consommation à l'échelle mondiale et
cette évolution qui procède de la
mondialisation des transports de
l'accélération de mobilité de
l'accélération de la communication à
travers internet et l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux etc tout cela un
sur les comportements qui est très fort
[Musique]